- You're.
(chuckles)
I'm laughing.
(gentle music)
My usual comedy routine is bad,
it's not good.
- A lot of self-deprecation,
a lot about dating.
- It's usually deadpan.
- It's topical, it's personal.
And a little dirty.
- [Interviewer] Could
you do something funny?
Okay, maybe you guys could just start off
getting to know each other.
- Have you been to a standup show before?
Have you ever done this to yourself?
- Sebastian, tell me
what you think is funny.
- Doggies, they're just funny in general?
- Are you ready.
(laughs)
I think they're gonna be able
to hear that pretty well.
- What's it like being so.
(laughs)
What's it like being so much
smaller than everyone else?
Is it weird?
- What's your favorite color crayon?
- Red!
- Red?
- Yeah.
- You know what's crazy
because the color red is the same thing
as when you read a book and
it's like the English language,
am I right?
- Wanna hear a knock knock joke?
- I know it already.
- You know it already?
(laughs)
- You know what's funny about this,
is I signed up for this,
I was like, oh great,
I'll be the comedian, turns
out, I think maybe it's you.
- What!
- Yeah!
Oh no is that not what, I was
supposed to be the funny one?
I'm failing miserably.
- Isn't it crazy when the teacher's like,
hey stop that, she sounds like.
(blows raspberry)
- Hey I'm Peppa Pig.
(laughs)
- Ahh, oh my god.
Do you like farts?
No?
- You like apple juice?
- Yeah.
- You ever think about how
there's no strawberry juice,
right?
It's like, what's that about?
- What if I sat in my chair
all funny like this maybe?
Or something, is this doing it for you?
- If you sit here, you
can have fruit snacks.
- I can do it for 10 minutes.
- You can do it for 10 minutes?
- I can do 10.
- One, two, three.
- What can I do that's funny?
- Pirate ship.
- What was that?
- A pirate ship.
- Yeah, arr.
- Okay, so pirate humor.
- Now listen, I feel like
that's a new form of heckling.
You just show me your shoes, I'll take it.
- Aye, here come the ships.
Set the sails.
(laughs)
Bring up the barge, ship stuff.
You gotta walk the plank, argh matey.
Argh argh argh.
- Nothing will make me laugh.
- Nothing will make you laugh.
Yeah I know, I know, I'm aware.
- [Interviewer] So how did it go?
- Terribly.
But you know, what are you
gonna do when you're not funny?
- Well he gave me some
notes, I might wanna focus
on pirate content.
Maybe some focus on doggies,
just nothing in general about,
just doggies in general.
(groans)
- Please, please, please please no!
Please, oh god, please no, no.